>>Daniel: For kids who really feel
like most of life happens to them,
for them to have an
opportunity to feel
that they have an impact
is very exciting.
The D3 program is designed
specifically for teenagers.
And they feel that it's really
relevant to their lives,
and relevant to the community
here, People Serving People.
>>Emily: One, two, three, jump!
Jennifer's trying to explain
the game we're about to play.
I think most of you played it.
It was called signs.
>>Daniel: People serving people is
the region's largest homeless shelter
for children and families.
But we're not a warehouse
for families.
Our whole purpose in being is
moving the kid and their folks
from a really desperate
situation towards self-sufficiency
as quickly as we can do it.
>>Kim: D3 in a nutshell is a process.
It's broken up into three parts,
which is Dream It,
Design It and Do It.
And this is a process all
professional designers use,
and it's really focusing on the how,
not necessarily just the
what, or the end result.
>>Emily: Should we walk
through it really quick?
>>Boy: Yeah.
>>Emily: We started
out in the beginning.
We took pictures with that
good, bad and the ugly activity.
We gave a thumbs up,
thumbs down, remember that?
>>Boy: Thumbs in the middle.
>>Emily: Yeah.
>>Kim: I think a lot of people
think the design process is very--
a mysterious kind of hidden thing
that happens behind the scenes.
And really what D3 does is
it demystifies that process.
There's no magic involved.
It's these very flexible,
but structured steps to walk
through and approach a problem.
>>Emily: There's six cards,
so they're going to go
on these littler circles,
not on the light bulbs,
but on these little
circles around, okay?
>>So this project started as
a spatial redesign project.
The teens wanted to redesign
or revamp a space at PSP
that they felt was
being underutilized
or that lacked a little pizzazz.
They wanted to put their
stamp on space here.
>>Boy: We had narrowed
down all the spaces.
Chose the three things that we liked
best, and we wanted to improve on.
>>Adam: Okay.
>>Boy: We chose the lobby.
>>Emily: They chose the lobby,
because it's chaotic, it's loud,
it's a very transitional space.
People are always coming and going.
And knew that that was
a space that they wanted
to add something to, add value to.
>>So what did we finally,
finally decide on?
Out of all of these ideas?
>>Boy: We made a map about
how people will find their way
around inside and outside PSP.
>>Emily: After brainstorming,
they found this map idea.
Creating a map of the neighborhood,
which would not only
bring people together,
because people travel quite a bit
together outside of the building,
but also bringing people
together physically in the lobby
over a new piece that
we'll be hanging.
We actually
canvassed the building.
We surveyed as many people
as we could, over 90 people.
And allowed them to sort
of give their feedback.
"Where do you go?
What kind of places do
you visit most often?
What places do you not visit?
What places could you go if you
had an afternoon to yourselves?"
>>Adam: We have a starter map.
So we haven't really done
much with this map yet,
but it's got the basic foundation.
So we have all the
streets in Minneapolis.
We got the Light Rail in here.
>>Joyce is a creative branding and
digital workshop, so we create logos
and brand identities for businesses,
as well as websites, and apps,
and that kind of a thing.
>>We have some of the
street names labeled,
but then we have all
these symbols and numbers.
You guys are going to
help us place those,
tell us where they are on this map.
And also...
>>Emily brought this project to
Joyce, knowing that they're looking
for kind of a local business, a local
creative shop partner that could sort
of showcase what it's like to be a
creative professional as a career.
>>We found where PSP
is headquartered.
It's Portland and Third.
And we started to find Gold
Medal Park, so that's up here.
We put a background in behind it.
Where else is something that's kind
of new there, we have the Guthrie.
>>Subway.
>>Adam: Subway.
Should we find where the subway is.
>>It's right there.
>>Adam: Right, Washington and Fifth.
>>Emily: We partnered with
Joyce to get this done.
They were a huge help.
They did all the backend design for
the map, and the kids went to Joyce
to help lay it out, and
pick colors, typefaces,
and really understand
how that came together.
>>Adam: You know what's
a nice on a map, Q2?
It lets us see that we have
a really consistent system
and that we're not-- nothing
looks too similar, right?
>>It's actually been
kind of fascinating,
because I think most kids,
and especially these kids
are curious by nature.
And when they come into kind
of a creative environment,
something they haven't seen
before, a lot of them kind of
come out of their shell a little bit.
And really want to engage and
understand how things translate
from just an idea to the end product.
>>So what color should we
use to indicate the park?
>>Green.
Like 'cause it says a peaceful place.
>>Adam: Yeah.
>>So just put it like
a whole bunch of grass right there.
>>Emily: We know that our
teens are extremely interested
in art and music and culture.
And Joyce is a place that blends all
of those with their work constantly.
So for the teens to learn from
young professionals that they see
as relevant people, that they see
as cool people, and to sort of learn
from them, to be under their wing,
I think is really transformative
for them.
They see something that they
otherwise wouldn't see anywhere else.
>>So where were we?
Right here?
>>Adam: Yep.
>>As well as right there.
>>Emily: It creates that pathway
in their brain from, "I like art,
and I'm good at art, or design, but
I don't know what I can do with it."
>>This is artwork.
This is me.
>>Woman: Wow, you did
a lot of work today!
>>Adam: Excellent,
yeah, this was a lot--
>>Emily: Guys, this
was four weeks of work!
>>Adam: This is a big project.
>>Boy: Yeah.
>>Emily: Four whole weeks.
Let's give ourselves
a round of applause.
[ applause ]
Whoo-hoo!
>>Adam: When you think about
applying and teaching design thinking
to really anyone, and especially
kids, it's again kind of getting
to the heart of empowerment
in my mind.
And giving them tools and processes
internally that they can use
to impact the world around them.
And instead of running
into a wall and deciding
that they can't go any
further, because they don't have
that brainstorming tool, or that
problem solving tool, they can think
of different ways that they
can move past that hurdle,
move past that obstacle,
and kind of get
on to the next thing in their life.
>>Boy: We had created a map
for people outside the state
that don't their way around.
And the map showed places where they
need to go, and how they get there.
>>Emily: The map now will
be hung in the lobby.
It will be hung right in front of the
front desk, so people who are waiting
for supplies, people who are
waiting to use the phone or laundry,
are able to look at this awesome
map that these teens created.
>>Let's give everyone
a round of applause.
[ applause, cheers ]
>>Ange: You need to
challenge students
because they'll rise to the occasion.
They'll rise to the
challenge you set forth.
And by putting students in the
context of a business environment,
or real world, you are requiring
them to rise to the challenge
and you're setting a high
expectation of how they're going to
perform, how they're going to behave.
The output that they're
going to produce.
And I can recreate that as much as
possible in a classroom setting,
but when you shift into a different
environment, the culture changes.
Your feelings change.
Everything about that changes.
You have authentic problems
and an authentic environment
in which you're solving them.
>>Daniel: I've heard from some of
the kids that they've been able
to apply what they're learning
in D3 into solving problems
that their families are facing,
in terms of selecting apartments,
and improving their housing.
This is a real opportunity for
them to feel genuinely engaged
and generally reinforce, and
that their ideas do have value,
and what they're doing does matter.
And in their lives
that's really quite rare.